usa la gráfica de abajo para decidir
cuáles de las siguientes ecuaciones son
ciertas nos muestran esta línea azul y
vemos que hay dos triángulos rectángulos
que están en esta línea y la tienen como
hipotenusa y aquí están todas las
ecuaciones que quieren que verifiquemos
si es que son ciertas con respecto a
esta gráfica
nosotros sabemos que la pendiente de
esta línea azul va a ser el cambio en y
entre el cambio en x
y si vemos estos triángulos y analizamos
con respecto a estos dos puntos este de
acá de estar acá podemos ver esta parte
de este lado ce como el cambio en g y de
cómo el cambio en x
lo mismo si analizamos estos dos puntos
de acá este y este otro este segmento a
es nuestro cambio en y nuestro segmento
b es el cambio en x y como hemos visto
anteriormente estos triángulos son
semejantes porque la pendiente de la
línea es constante podemos decir que
nuestro segmento c
entre el segmento d
va a ser igual esta proporción va a ser
la misma que la del segmento
entre el segmento b está ahí está esta
proporción va a ser la misma muy bien
también nos están indicando este punto
de aquí x y vamos a analizar cada una de
estas ecuaciones para ver si son
verdaderas solo la primera nos dice que
más cuatro entre x + 4 es igual a entre
b vamos a ver aquí está mi punto x y
james 4 quiere decir que es este punto
de acá bueno este segmento que es que
todo este valor y a éste le agrego 4 1 2
3 4 llegó hasta acá entonces james 4 es
esta línea una vez
de este mismo punto me dicen que a x que
es este valor le agregue 4 también se
los puedo agregar hacia la derecha o
hacia la izquierda
para claridad me conviene agregarlos
hacia la izquierda este es mi valor en x
que lo puedo también tener aquí y a este
valor x que es este de aquí le agrego 4
1 2 3 4
muy bien entonces tengo este segmento de
acá en morado y este segmento
como esta parte es perfectamente
horizontal y esta parte es como
perfectamente vertical forman un ángulo
recto es un triángulo rectángulo y como
están estos puntos sobre esta misma
línea representa la misma pendiente y va
a ser semejante en proporción va a ser
igual en proporción a estos otros
triángulos que están sobre esta misma
línea así que vamos a poner estas
naranjita como
y este de aquí abajo la morada es
x + 4 x los 4
podemos decir que esta proporción entre
b es igual a la proporción de más 4
llevamos 4 que es el lado que
corresponde al lado a entre x 4 que es
el lado que le corresponde al lado b
este de acá abajo x + 4
estos son iguales en proporción por lo
que esta es verdadera las siguientes x +
4 entre yemas 4 iguala a / de bueno de
hecho esto está mezclada porque pues a
ese lado de un triángulo y de ese lado
de otro trípoli como que no tienen nada
que ver entre ellos así que no de
entrada esto está mal porque tiene los
términos revueltos la siguiente b entre
a igual a c / d
de hecho no no es así porque vemos aquí
que se es proporcional a a y d es
proporcional a b son los lados
correspondientes y aquí pues está
invertido y aquí no es así entonces
bueno esta opción no es la última opción
se entre de iguala a entre b pues si es
exactamente lo que tenemos aquí arriba
en la misma proporción así que esta
última opción si es verdadera
con esto terminamos de resolver el
problema que nos piden